[Musique]
vous voulez contrôler votre rue et dans
la vie tout n'est pas quantifiable
vous pourrez paraît éternellement
maîtriser votre environnement
faites-vous peur pendant ses congés
d'accord oui
cette carte est un billet d'entrée soyez
le premier à vous échapper et
empochèrent millions de dollars le jeu
commence quand
je crois que celle escape room cherchant
des indices
on dirait le bouton de réglage d'un four
je trouvais pas quelque chose
comment sort des six 6 farenheit 451 gpg
ça c'est ce que j'appelle une immersion
question idiote on est vraiment de horn
ça lui sera ça
ils savent absolument du sud ils ont
créé ce jeu tourne où vous avez déjà vu
des choses apparaître comme par magie
je ne suis pas en train de rêver
survivre est un choix
voilà pourquoi ils ont choisi un bo
[Musique]